pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle eddy baelemans reporter à
paris nouvelle
ce matin là je venais d'arriver au
journal j'étais au laboratoire en train
de développer un reportage sur le
mariage d'un violoniste virtuose et
d'une championne de catch quand on
m'annonce à que le rédacteur en chef me
demandais d'urgence mais trop longs vers
autre chose dans le même esprit c'est
toi je voulais te voir bombe à danneberg
je sais que nous préférons une page
spéciale apportez moi le dossier
battenberg s'il vous plaît l'archiduc
charles réunis dans son genou abonnés
libe
présentant ce week end royal dont le
secrétariat de l'archiduc ne pas révéler
les motifs participeront entre autres la
reine une romy l'infante d'espagne
nous avons les photos de tous les
invités de l'archiduc charles les ans
dont une seule celle de maria shriver
est la fille du dictateur
oui on a fait un truc à dans la tendance
qui sait ce qu'il s'agit de trouver mais
pour le moment ils me font marié à
gregor elle est à paris depuis ce matin
elle doit essayer cet après-midi les
robes qu'elle emportera à bazeilles
direct j'ai besoin avant ce soir de sa
photo dans une de ses robes
débrouille-toi débrouille-toi les
breuilletois facile a dit oui au devoir
a toujours interdit en ces travaux
que sa fille soit photographiée en
voyage avait accompagné de sa
gouvernante amelia du colonel guerrero
et de deux gardes du corps est mort seul
le visage caché par une voilette noire
alors pour la photographier
pendant ce temps dans l'atelier de raimu
si les demoiselles les petites mains à
la langue agile papote solidement maria
gregor mystère regardez moi j'ai
exactement sa taille c'est bon ça ne me
suis pas arrêté de callas une barque
elle est très belle
en tout cas son père a toujours interdit
qu'on la photographie
et bien mes demoiselles on va attendre
mieux de travailler
corinne allait immédiatement préparer un
cigare de mademoiselle brigue horde
qu'est ce que ces valeurs de base non
monsieur ça tombe vraiment très mal
regardez ce pli la dame tôt
ça va pas du tout
petite erreur madame louise aux dépens
de l'est
[Musique]
voilà
ceret paris mais nous souhaitons
vraiment très mal la russie revient
mademoiselle
nous allions
prendre la tête avec ça sinon c'est
entièrement c'est complètement raté
monsieur à moisn ange michel de rémy
alors
voilà mes premiers
1h24 ça ne sera jamais réparer des sites
en russie je ne fais pas ça va mais
maria maria vous ne pouvez pas faire ça
la baisse des mines aux grecs à tout
faire non mademoiselle
il ya peut-être un moyen de tout
arranger corinne dans les accompagner à
bellelay de bergues et sur place elle
fera les retouches
n'est ce pas corinne à la sinon ça
arrange tout et avec elle ça tombe bien
avec corinne est notre meilleure
ouvrière
vous verrez elle est idéale une
merveille ça vous n'aurez qu'à vous en
féliciter mon petit allez vite vous
préparer non pas tout de suite j'ai
encore deux semaines pour freiner et
combien de temps une heure 29 minutes 30
secondes je peux compter sur vous donc
madame louise et des madmoizelles gregor
à défaut et fantasmagorie s'est passé
monsieur sur yon c'est le photographe
officiel de réfugiés
gérard dériot vous avez juste 20 minutes
pour immortaliser coup ça m'a plombé les
caisses dans une tanière le train de
tâter terre par à 19 heures je travaille
ici pas de moi celle des rigoles
aux foulées à des corinne mademoiselle
gregor est parti à l'écran l'histoire
par la porte de derrière sens du retour
de pavillons c'est la crise c'est à ce
moment là
pendant que mes distinguer confrères
pourrait sans espoir à la poursuite de
maria gregor que j'ai eu la plus géniale
idée de ma carrière et qui aller
m'entraîner sans que je m'en doute dans
une aventure extra
bolloré mazel au travail
[Musique]
au vu des solides
c'est entièrement ma faute place demande
pardon c'est typique aux cèpes atteindra
30 à mourir pour ça ça demande à faire
un petit costard à viable
parfait c'est un scoop formidable nous
avons passé des le colonel sommes les
seuls à avoir des photos de mariah
gregor ai dit tu as réussi un coup de
maître puisque tu as bien commencé tu
continues tu parles base ldc que evelyne
dictature de préparer une avance 2003
pour eddy il pensait prendre tout de
suite et vous lui réservez une couchette
dont paris viennent de ce soir
tu es très jolie tue à dire d'une
princesse qui n'aurait pas dû mettre le
paillage et maman de sueur et mission la
protection pour le voyage
corinne la petite couturière fait
rapidement ses préparatifs pour son
premier voyage dans le grand monde sans
se douter de l'aventuré fabuleuse
qu'elle va vibre termine tard a dit j'ai
tout même de préparer un petit moment
la petite corinne qu'il reviendra
peut-être jamais de balle dahlberg
tribune pour moi vous fait plaisir
tu leur bien pratique autant des stats
ont rappelé ailleurs il faut toujours
suivre son destin
quand un gars tu te voilà encore reparti
nantes et caen guilels demandé relais a
pris le bateau pour aller en
cornouailles
elle ne se doutait pas que ce qu'elle
est lui arrivé qu'est ce que tu racontes
en europe pour le bonheur tu n'as pas lu
dans par nouvelle lettre mais derrière
non moi je ne nie que les histoires tu
verras ma chérie j'étais peut-être le
règle on fait la réalité
corinne la voiture et là je file dis
leur que j'arrive à avoir ce ne sont pas
les premiers à voir
obama se lit on se dira j'ai tout
entendu il n'y a pas une seconde à
perdre les journalistes
sur la piste de votre hôtesse il me
reste encore deux personnages à vous
présenter ce jeune directeur de garage
et prince en exil
philippe fils du roi de béru vie détrôné
par milos gregor et son confident le
quand fabregas supris votre un test de
faire confiance au premier ministre du
roi rappelle
attention cause
[Musique]
hélas
non
où allez-vous chez mademoiselle maria
callas gore oui j'apporte les fleurs de
la part de son excellence l'ambassadeur
de béru vit à paris bon allez merci
beaucoup
et alors c'est quand même moi j'aime le
mariage rigueur de la part de tous c'est
l'ampleur des senteurs de verigy arrive
pendant ce temps là mon idée géniale
fait son petit bonhomme de chemin et une
simple photographie va déclencher une
série de réactions en chaîne
dépassant toute prévision et toute
espérance le train des rotatives le
destin sont en marche rien ne peut plus
les arrêter par une nouvelle bibenne ouf
au tour de marianne d'or
tout à l'heure je vous retrouverai comme
convenu à la gare frontière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avez-vous fait bon voyage
on aurait bien une tâche de telles
bombes abbey à dater
[Musique]
merci à bercy derrière l air de rien je
ne juge pas je résume
et depuis lors il règne dans toute la
baie rugby font du droit
il règne une agitation provoquée par le
misérable rico de chef de vos partisans
et même une guerre à supportable et
subversives contre le général tu rigoles
gouvernement à qui je vous le rappelle
le gouvernement légal et l'officiel de
la pyrrhus
le gouvernement que je vous présente le
gouvernement
peut être la espionner mais si ce
contrôle controverse vient contrôler les
billets les belges de pamiers
je me permets d'en haut niveau
[Musique]
il aurait d'après marié sa fille maria
est l'héritier du trône le prince
philippe héritier du titre le 3
n'existent plus parce que de votre
propre théorie que vous avez décidé
qu'il n'existait plus mais enfin le
prince philip en est pas moins
descendant des rois de béru vie vous
savez aussi bien que moi s'amuse ici
qu'est ce que c'est
je vais m'excuser nous arrivons dans
trois minutes exactement la faute et
bien colonel guerrero je dois vous
rappeler que le prétendant que nous
sommes disposés à vous accorder est un
jeune homme sain de belle prestance une
haute intelligence et dans notre
apparente est l une des familles
régnantes les plus anciennes de parole
il est à figer d'idées démocratique est
ridiculement libérales qui sont un
danger nationale n'est tout de même pas
reprocher ce fils de roi d'être trop
république monsieur le comte l'anarchie
n'est pas la république
en danse les pouces que vous nous
proposez dont je ne conteste ni les
charmes physique ni les qualités morales
maria un roc les solides comme la charge
d'assurer un char d'assaut qui auraient
des crises de son mobile pour en
soulevant pas c'est une histoire en sus
elle est qui lui manque dans son enfance
marié avec une équipe yannick on gagne
quoi tous ces gens voient la personne
n'a pu le noeud pote 3.20 pas les
guerres pour des galibots totalement
vierge ou moins d'ailleurs les syndicats
[Musique]
nous sommes un acteur
peu revanchard compte et rassurer bien
le prince marier avec dairy est
définitivement guéri
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà plein débat
six personnes
alors on danse hip hop là
[Musique]
et tu es tu y vas martin fallet matmos
elle quitta ses nems pers
six jeunes vieux kick and cheese and
alors de boudreau jeune homme allons
allons allons certains de ses rêves est
vrai
vers l'est pas
enel avait donné la consigne à suresnes
tu n'as pas affecté d'un concile mon
colonel
c'est mon coloc quoi sinon la cua tu
sais ce que tu mérites toi la mort mon
collègue quoi ou quoi un an de retard
pour l'instant il faut la retrouver la
même pas du sont abolies et non regarder
quoi ces vêtements leurs ébats ses
vêtements sont tous là
non
[Musique]
ces petits crétins de quattro leur droit
de nous attendre à des lobbies via lui
je le reconnaît l'excellence ainsi la
cloris lui mais c'est un espion de
mortier nous pouvons faire des choses
pour est agréable et monsieur le
ministre mais comment on fait mais ce
monsieur n'à compartiment comme
voyageurs clandestins mais je ne suis
pas contestable
j'ai mon billet je vais le présenter
dans dit monsieur il n'a pas je regarde
pas savoir tirer
finalement fin mai pour injure à une
éminente personnalité étrangère et la
police occupe en arriver là pierre patry
[Musique]
j'espère ça y est c'est au tour des mois
avec avec la victoire du oui
vont continuer jusqu'à manning bien et
vous prévenez l'archiduc charles que
maria est un petit peu retardé et elle
arrivera plus tard dans la soirée
non parce que si j'avais eu la brague on
a laissé partir sa vie mais ce sera trop
tard
monsieur le ministre est c'est fait il
est bouclé les autres tu arrêtes de
traque
oui monsieur le ministre il sert à ton
prochain à reims une demi heure où le
fait arrêter tout de suite silence une
milice je dois descendre pour une
affaire d'état alors bull pas t'arrêter
vous fait reculer jusqu'à la station 3
pierre précédant celle au trinquet
variés un maillon d'or pour le fait
d'arrêter tout de suite c'est dans
l'écouté je compte 80 m sur l'exigence
échec
ce soir le ps
[Musique]
ayobi ma valise et mon costume bits
oh
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
sa vocation de bananes berg et je viens
dernière fois on a commandé la
discrétion la plus absolue
personne ne doit savoir que mademoiselle
maria gregor a disparu mais je vous
répète personne ne doit savoir n'est ce
pas alors elle est retardée
enfin il fait des courses et il fallait
d'occuper il n'a pas détaillé les
retarder maintenant c'est entendu à la
descente du mademoiselle greg l'hymne
national de bruit et tout à l'heure au
château pour le prince philip lim
mont-royal de bruit surtout pas
d'erreurs ça pourrait créer un incident
très regrettable
oui bon signal monseigneur le train est
annoncé
merci
l'archiduc charles a invité dans son
château de berenberg
tous les souverains régnant ou en exil
parmi ses invités se trouve marjah
gregor la fille du dictateur de béru vie
que son père voudrait marier avec le
prince philip le fils du roi qui l'a
détrôné maria gregor est passé par paris
pour essayer ses toilettes
elle emmène avec elle une jeune ouvrière
corinne chargé des dernières retouches
le journal paris nouvelles publie par
erreur une photo de corinne à la place
de celle de maria et au cours du voyage
la fille du dictateur qui est somnambule
disparaît
voilà
mettez moi de me présenter charles de
batz bloomberg
bonjour mais si cela m'arrive
bourgneuf
bonjour
[Musique]
là
fla
pourquoi
[Musique]
un puits
charmant personnage
[Musique]
s
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
dans ce livre badley le vétérinaire est
il venu
oui mon seigneur le check up de machines
étaient pris fin oui mon seigneur pour
les donnerait de la viande rôtie
monseigneur je compte la mener à la
charge
monseigneur merci bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est le même nom les vagues de perdre
on engageons que des jumeaux on disait
mademoiselle à son appartement
l'appartement de l'impératrice
marie-louise oil
l'essai cette fleur
[Musique]
le parrot et la baronne 2,8 m bour
le prince profit de fontfroide lundi
broker fils
[Musique]
e
comme si j
et nous allons
c'est bon ça c'est très bon quelle vue
merveilleuse
ici vous pouvez voir tous les actes et
routier petit [ __ ] mais des fenêtres
donnent sur la forêt et le curage
dalphond
jetez pas votre bagage lui
meunier
je suis là pour ça maintenant
alors faisons le ensemble
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sympathique pour autant de titres
derrière j'ai vu son corps par exemple
journal
elle est très mignonne comme tout à
l'heure au déjeuner à fayyad va manger
comme une grosse cachin parole je pense
que de manger comme petit voyou un gros
petits soins sont alors son altesse
royale le prince philippe de belgique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je fais
les seuls services madame
tic malheureuse mont d'or
vous n'avez donc pas compris que
l'archidiocèse a prises pour maria
gregor oui vous vous a vu arriver par le
même train qu'elle descendre du wagon
spécial
il a tout naturellement pensé et quand
j'ai voulu lui expliquer cette maudite
musique m'a coupé la parole et vous au
lieu lui dire tout de suite la vérité
même à berwyn le mariage il ne m'a rien
demandé
enfin concept petite fille me vous
offrir des fleurs
je pensais qu'on fait ça tous les
voyages
quand le colonel guerre où sera ce que
vous avez fait il dire à deux mots à
votre réussite vous verrez ce que ça va
vous coûter madame je vous assure que je
n'ai rien fait a justement vous avez
laissé faire et c'est là votre crime un
crime de lèse majesté assimile aux
règles savez que vous avez pris la place
de sa fille vous préfériez mais la
fameuse dame je les ai pris la place de
personne et après tout c'est vous qui
avez la responsabilité maria gregor
c'est vous qui l'avez laissé échapper du
tracé vous qui méritait d'être fusillé
oh non non et la gare c'était avoue
d'expliquer les choses à l'archiduc au
lieu de rester planté là comme une
idiote et puisque vous êtes incapable de
vous faire comprendre c'est moi qui vais
tout dire anarchie duc
mademoiselle maria kregor
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
m
[Musique]
ates monseigneur je doive représentait
le prince philippe de belgique moselle
puis solliciter la faveur de vous
entretenir l instant prince mon cher
philippe je vous ramène mademoiselle
greg a tout de suite il faut d'abord que
je lui fasse connaître nos invités s'il
vous plaît mademoiselle je vous présente
d'abord à mon épouse notre jeune invité
mademoiselle greg bienvenus
le prince royal
roberto sfax et le prince impérial top
ou quatre temps le baron et la baronne
d'être venu borloo comme sa majesté la
reine j'ai remis
mademoiselle je suis heureuse de vous
voir ici majesté le compte de fabregas
c'est mieux je voulais prendre un peu de
repos avant le déjeuner
après
oui
[Applaudissements]
je vois c'est reparti ma présence
[Musique]
mais
moise elle s'est perdue je pense
monsieur si mademoiselle veux bien me
suivre
oui
mademoiselle maria gregor qui est
incurable de petitesse et les sept nains
pop ne savent pas qu'on invente sa ferme
un bon gros film mademoiselle greg ne se
sont pas très bien
ayez la gentillesse de la reconduire
dans sa chambre mais si demain cette
petite me plaît beaucoup
[Musique]
à la peine
écoutez toute façon je ne serai pas dans
cette maison matters oui parfaitement t
on aller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la gendarmerie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est de vous dire à angers mais en fait
voilà monsieur le brigadier je suis un
touriste bilan ce moment je visite le
thymol alors j'avais avec moi ma fille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
brest a pu se mettre au soleil qu'il
faut monsieur brigadier je suis marié
avec la fille de minos gregor le
président de la république de père et
fille cette saisie shaolan la semaine
est finie avec monseigneur on demande à
votre altesse au téléphone de la
gendarmerie de bruce lee berg tous les
respects monseigneur excusez-moi
d'importuner votre altesse mais je dois
urgemment signaler à votre altesse
qu'est ce que vous racontez brigade greg
est arrivé si ce matin par le train
spécial soyez gentil brigadier nommé
déranger plus pour des histoires aussi
la terre bazizi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo mirent à devenir central canaries
ça râle cadario 5,5 ont consommé ici
mais un jeune nantais message rossignol
acrobatique
envoyez l'urgence
j'attends battenberg agent secret cette
scène peinture à biomasse compris aux
missions ultra confidentiel informatique
eh bien puisque tous nos chers parents
et invités sont là nous allons pouvoir
passer à table ils mentent rarement on
s'emballe serait pire pas moi elle me
changer un peu de la famille ben j'ai
ramé l'avez vous fait prévenu oui j'ai
envoyé quelqu'un à sa chambre sa
gouvernante m'a fait dire que la jeune
personne était malade et qu'elle me
suppliait de l'excusé si elle ne
paraissait pas obliger les vols départ
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais je parlais à son altesse darchy du
la part du coup donald déroule quand
même je vous présente mes devoirs je
vous prie de bien vouloir excuser mon
retard la gouvernante l'a sans doute
expliqué ne soyez pas inquiets
tout va bien la gouvernante et auprès
des madmoizelles greg auprès de balboa
est d'accord mais alors parfait mais pas
fait donc soyez sans inquiétude des
senneurs elle sera totalement rétabli
merci monseigneur alors moi je vous prie
encore de bien vouloir excuser ce retard
quelques affaires comme ça deux
dernières heures au dernier moment mais
je suis vraiment vraiment ravi désolé
mais j'arriverai sans poids de ce soir à
baden bien je vous présente mes devoirs
monseigneur mes devoirs alors ça nous va
bien maria et retrouver le touche-à-tout
à baden
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la situation est tragique maintenant je
ne peux plus sortir d'ici tout bien sûr
mais heureusement vous empêchera de
faire de nouvelles bêtises je peux dire
alors j'ai dû que je ne suis pas marié
gray corps après ce que vous avez fait
nous il faut attendre que le colonel
reviennent avec maria oui c'est au
château de baden berg à la suite d'un
quiproquo
corinne petites ouvrières parisienne a
été prise pour la fille du dictateur de
béru vie maria gregor qui s'est perdue
dans la campagne a été recueillie par
des paysans amelia la gouvernante de
maria a tant que celles ci étaient
retrouvés pour révéler la vérité je
viens desservir encore vous sortez
immédiatement
c'est lui que j'ai l'espion cette petite
n'a pas paru au déjeuner parce que vous
l'avez tous frigorifié avec vos mine du
grand nord
maintenant je vous la corde cette petite
charmant mais le n'a aucune espèce
d'éducation vous avez vu cette façon
d'entrer dans le salon sans avoir été
annoncé charles vous parlez toujours
sans avoir c'est herman qu'il a trop
vite les gloires sa valise à la main
j'ai essayé de s'enfuir parce que
peut-être peur moi oui vous et tous ces
vieux fossile est petit et sont ainsi
facilement impressionnable il faut pas y
toucher c'est ici
c'est encore j'ai eu une idée vous
entendez fut celle que j'appelle la
police et là c'était lui non la reine
chez remy l'énarchie elle est trop drôle
elle s'est déguisée obligèrent ma tante
je suis désolé laissons la sq a doublé
tout de suite présenter vos excuses à la
reine je n'oserai jamais je vous donne
rien c'est pas celle vous l'avez non à
ses obligations diplomatiques vous le
recevez vous dit rien pas un mot rien
silence quoi qu'il vous demande vous ne
répondez pas vous êtes m mais
mademoiselle vous prie de bien vouloir
l'excuser l'a tellement surprise de voir
votre thèse ailleurs cette porte là
depuis demandé de me laisser l'instant
seul avec un modèle gore ah non ça ce
n'est pas possible le protocole j'en
fais mon affaire
et d'ailleurs d'ailleurs je ne dirai
rien
je serai m m merci madame
[Musique]
paix intérieure à laquelle aspire notre
pays nous contraignent tous deux accepté
un mariage que nous avons souhaité ni à
une autre
[Musique]
je m'engage à respecter votre liberté et
de respecter la mienne je pense que vous
serez d'accord
[Musique]
il s'agit là uniquement d'un mariage de
raison d'un contrat politique il ne peut
bien entendu en aucun cas être question
d'autre chose entre nous
vous êtes certainement à vide ce pas
l oise est peut-être ne comprenez vous
pas ce que j'essaie de vous expliquer
c'est pourtant qu'un simple je ne vous
aime pas je n'ai aucune intention de
vous aimer mon seigneur je vous ai très
bien compris vous ne venez pas de moi
non plus je ne vous aime pas et je nous
ai posera jamais
un gros coup excusez moi je prends merci
mademoiselle de votre franchise qui
règle définitivement cette question je
vais mieux fait de ne pas vous écoutez
fabregas et de ne pas venir perdre mon
temps madame des jeux mais costaud ce
pigment seigneur d'avoir une discussion
et moisé leurs corps font tous les deux
tombés d'accord sur ce mariage est bien
réelle ni moi ne voulons entendre parler
c'est impossible
c'est un malentendu nous assure qu'il
n'ya pas de malentendu s'est expliqué
très clairement très nettement et pour
moi l'affairé réglée mais monseigneur
cette nuit même avec le colonel berrod
nous avons établi le protocole du
mariage qui doit être célébrée dans
trois mois
eh bien il se célébrera son moi et sans
elle je vous dis qu'elle n'en veut pas
grieder n'est certainement pas
responsables je devine une intrigue une
manoeuvre destinée à paralyser l'action
des partisans du roi il faut absolument
garder la tête froide
monseigneur monseigneur je vous en
conjure l'entreprenant rien avant que
j'ai pu contacter le colonel dayraut
skoda les reventes ont dérivé vous soyez
déjà enfermée dans un cachot à 100
mètres sous terre
nous ne sommes pas un bruit je vais
téléphoner à paris savait très bien que
ce n'est pas possible maintenant entrer
madame on vous demande au téléphone
c'est de la part du colonel guerrero à
l'eau colonel je suis à la gare
frontière
j'ai manqué le frein ma voiture est en
panne
on vous attend avec impatience plus fort
je vous entends très mal jeudi on vous
attend avec impatience vous permettez
vous alors excusez moi mademoiselle mais
je vous supplie ne l'écouté c'est très
important
retrouvez de berne on vous dit que vous
l'avez retrouvé en attendant ouais ben
okba temps de m'attarder vrai moi aussi
à quel soulagement
je me suis fait un souci alors dit
abardia quel pouvoir ouvrir le bal avec
le frère mes coups colonel à l'eau
colonna
on a beaucoup c'est ma première portable
si je réussis mon avenir est assuré
c'est déjà grâce à moi que votre photo a
paru hier dans paris nouvelle c'est
gentil la première photo de vous qui
paraît dans la presse française
ah non il y en a déjà eu une bonne
nouvelle impossible pari au jeu pour les
moyens de parler avec vous mais je suis
bien certain qu'il ya pas eu photo
[Musique]
regardez c'est une photo prise dans
l'atelier de rimouski le jour de la
sainte catherine
mais on dit pas dans la légende que vous
étiez ce jour-là en visite chez réussi
ici je suis tous les jours je
travaillerai moussy comment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
renoncules appel violette alors
renoncules appel violette
oui ici renoncules halo violette c'est
vous vous m'entendez
oui ici c'est renoncules prévenez
urgence est un major fleur de lys
d'envoyer château battenberg tyrol agent
secret rex 33
[Musique]
et
non
château de bataille ouverte
allô allô allô ici renoncules 17 états
majors fleur de lys allons parler parler
oui hystérique korhogo
quelle est la situation excellente mais
commando se sentent à filtrer dans tous
les postes clés des rebelles
les bombes sont en place ricoh je
voulais déjà dit il ne faut rien
précipiter
bien entendu mon cher quand dès que l'on
annonce officiellement le mariage du
prince et de la fille rebelle pour
l'instant alors il n'ya plus
d'hésitation je vais tout a sauté à
l'eau rico attendez je vous accorde 48
heures mais sans 48 heures je n'ai pas
de réponse je vous préviens que vous
sauter tous les corps ico alors si le
mariage ne se fait par ricco menace de
mettre la mairie vie à feu et à sang
c'est un fou dangereux dites-moi compte
pourquoi nos partisans sont ils toujours
de telles excité ce n'est pas nous qui
les choisit son seigneur ce sont eux qui
nous choisissent de bien dommage
monseigneur me croyez vous pas qu'il
faut absolument éviter la guerre civile
que des visites au centre soit sacrifiée
que des hommes des femmes des enfants
soit immolé sur l'autel de la patrie
mon cher compte parlons clairement si je
comprends bien on attend de moi que je
me sacrifie sur l'autel de la patrie
pour le bonheur du peuple et pour la
glorieuse satisfaction de mon père et
ses amis
qu'est-ce que ça
c'est notre argent
en seniors devront agents rx30 3 pour
l'instant ernest dupont dupond
électricien au service de votre altesse
et de son excellence nous avons besoin
de vous
[Musique]
m
le mariage soit prête pour la base de ce
soir le colonel aras mais il veut
absolument que la ciste au bal il ne
devrait pas tarder il devrait être là
demain
casimir dubois électricien oui et alors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je m'excuse madame un court circuit dans
la bibliothèque et je dois vérifier la
boîte de jonction il se trouve ici
sans lui la place en coin
[Musique]
va bien pour vous
oui
[Musique]
et vous aussi monsieur oui
oui ça m'a
ça coûtait voir mademoiselle je vous
rappelle que vous ne devez sous aucun
prétexte parlé au prince
ni lui adresser le moindre signe le plus
petit sourire comme un coucou
vous avez raison monsieur le comte
ils ont l'intention de saboter le projet
de mariage prennent la forme d'un procès
très bien très bien que ça suffit pour
l'instant arrêté va clore dites moi
fabregas si nous parlions après tout
projet volonté monseigneur allons sur le
balcon si vous voulez bien plus rien je
dû mettre des micros sur le balcon tracy
n'a pas non nous paiement la santé j'ai
peut-être un moyen de connaître les
intentions les plus secrètes de ces
individus c'est intéressant chercher le
fruit de mes recherches personnelles
l'ananas bombe ananas à l'extérieur à
l'état ce sont des cigares ou pas totale
on enfume et on dit la vérité toute la
vérité rien que la vérité des jo et je
fais même pas s'il ya un mois
ah oui non mais c'est pas pour vous sont
des cigares ils proviennent du lieu
manufacture de tabac en belgique vous à
nos frais au prince philippe de la part
du compte des rô le prince enfume il en
fait fumer au congo il parle
nous écoutons et nous savons toute la
vérité rien
la vérité de dieu je rigole
voyant que j'avais bien je ne fume pas
voir vos merci pour excuser moi madame
les plans de la bibliothèque encore
sauté et je dois vérifier la boîte de
jonction qui se baigne ici se trouve ici
ou là d'être bien conseillé du château
les installations c
[Musique]
je me sied casimir dubois elle reste du
pur mais appeler ou internet
[Applaudissements]
on est électricien tous les autres
électriciens et collègues alors en en
boire un coup et risquent toujours de
l'électricité un ouais pas vous
pas pour longtemps
[Musique]
ça m'a été offert
[Applaudissements]
à les aider et qui c'est qui vous les a
offerts je place mon corps va dire que
l'algérie libre à l'édito de la mairie
mais ils valent à dire de plus en plus
les plus en plus fort pic est de plus en
plus à des mesures
[Musique]
l'annoncé ici non non non malfaisante
ici regardez moi oui nanard mal à vous
n'êtes pas qu'on finance
oui je ne suis pas casimir du bois ah
oui oui elle a dit mir boy stocks lui au
col de chouf jeu les bouffer troisième
année deuxième cycle premier cycle
confidence pour confidence puisqu'on est
honnête
autant s'en servir j'ai posé là de
l'ananas sur l'a31 à na na nana na na no
9 mai macallan celui qui était dans la
corbeille mais je ne sais pas ce que moi
qui les manches et heureusement vous
vous en seriez un père si walt whitman
s'était spécialement destiné aux
principes il y tient beaucoup
eh bien vous dire presque son ananas
n'est plus chez moi le majordome a dû
l'emporter avec la corbeille
la palène à masisi
boucher
ce temps là c est caché une boîte à
musique eu des destinées à mademoiselle
creek humaniser privés directs vers mu
ans venez nous aider
il entreprend la naïveté cnai des sept
moines à musique
accor
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors 9 9 bis rue est bloquée la station
frontières il a plus tard aujourd'hui il
arrivera que tu l'as trouvé marianne
lagord il paraît qu oui mais ne vient
pas avec n pourquoi comment pourquoi je
comprends et d'or se plaint mystère kahn
est honteux déguisées en électrices sun
micro par tout perdre ici on entend tout
ce qui se passe dans gm
figurez vous ma chère que le gendarme me
racontait qu'il avait tard est une folle
qui se prenait pour ma vie à greg
elle disait que elle était descendue du
train à la gare frontière et qu'on
l'avait laissé sur nick et les gens
lisent grand dérangement
ça leur mental ap un formidable gens
prêtent une voiture historique
mais s'il arrive entre bien qu'une seule
route pour venir ici la rencontre
ouvrait forcément j'avais chaque fois
pas pu y est encore là bas est là mais
sympa pas non plus ces importuns
sensationnel
photo ch
[Musique]